bon le trailer d'avengers kanouté
sérieux la piquer mon bon rat savage
rigoler le trailer d'avengers cat est
enfin sorti et whaou
il réussit à noailles paix tout en ne
dévoilant que peu de choses je suis
conquis néanmoins il y a des choses tout
de même à tirer de ce trailer et suite à
notre live débat sur le trailer et nos
échanges les amis je vous propose 3
petite théorie concernant avengers 4 et
bien évidemment en compagnie des héros
on célèbre acolyte
bien le bonjour aux voyageurs allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'était assez évident et je suis fier
d'avoir mis le doigt dessus
dans des récentes vidéos entre man et la
clé scénaristique d'avengers 4 du moins
c'est ce que nous montre le trailer
et c'est justement pourquoi j'aime ce
trailer c'est que leurs réponses sont à
mener de manière subtile un trailer très
lourd triste et on constate les
conséquences de thanos du moins jusqu'à
ce que scott lang alias ant man arrive
redonne un certain espoir
tout d'abord rappelons aux 2/3 du fond
sur ce qu'était devenu antoine pendant
le combat contre thanos ce dernier était
sous surveillance policière à cause des
événements de civil war
puis suite à plusieurs péripéties dante
man 2 ce dernier a appris à appréhender
le champ quantique à l'aide de hank la
guêpe ainsi que la mère de cette
dernière
cependant lors d'une mission dans la
dimension parallèle ce dernier se
retrouve coincé seul dans le champ
quantique
car ces trois compères ont disparu du au
claquement de doigts de thanos sa porte
de sortie est un vortex temporel
c'est le seul indice qui nous a été
donné dans cette scène post générique
il est évident que scott l'a empruntée
on ne va pas y aller par quatre chemins
je ne suis plus sûr à 100% mais à 200 %
que les avengers et du coup scott
langues vont manipuler le temps et
voyager pour arriver à une conclusion
plus joyeuse comment le prouver
la dernière celle du trailer
introduisant le retour de scott amène
une ouverture pendant que steve et
natacha sens dans le robert des avengers
une vidéo surgit soudainement des
archives c'est antoine qui leur demande
d'ouvrir la porte et qu'il est de retour
au premier abord on se dit ouais il est
de retour c'est cool il va sauver le
truc mais il est fort c'est que la scène
soit plus profonde que ça déjà comment
antoine a pu sortir de la dimension
quantique
on peut supposer que quelqu'un soit venu
l'aider pour en sortir certains pensent
à doctor strange revenu en tant que
corps astral voyageant dans la dimension
ou encore captain marvel
étant donné qu'elle tire ses pouvoirs du
chant quantique mais c'est une fausse
route
scott se présente tout seul devant les
avengers il n'est accompagné de
personnes cela veut donc dire qu'il a
réussi à sortir du champ quantique par
le biais du vortex temporel en solo
maintenant il faut s'intéresser au
dialogue notamment concernant
v natacha j'étais super grand c'est un
ancien messages en mode je suis sûr
qu'on se connaît c'est la porte
principale
c'est moi quelqu'un peut me la phrase de
steve confirme que la vidéo est ancienne
et qu'elle n'est pas actuelle d'après
moi antoine aurait envoyé cette vidéo du
passé par le biais du vortex temporel
pour qu'elle soit vue par steve à ce
moment précis il ya forcément quelque
chose là-dessus pourquoi la vidéo
proviendrait des archives à scott ne
maîtrise pas des vortex temporel et dieu
sait à quelle époque il a pu atterrir
le seul problème reste le camion son
véhicule est le même que celui du film
antoine de transportant la machine pour
accéder au chant quantique il crée donc
un souci temporel car cela voudrait dire
que nous sommes toujours dans le présent
bref le trailer nous donne que très peu
d'indicés mais scott semble être
vraiment l'espoir du film et le fait que
la vidéo proviennent des archives n'est
pas anodin je suis certain que scott a
envoyé cette vidéo du passé
cette idée provient que d'une seule
image du trailer et pourtant je suis sûr
que ça arrivera au milieu de tout ce
désespoir captain america black widow
semble avoir un plan combat à mener
pourtant thanos a disparu avec les
pierres et le gant il va falloir bien
creuser pour noah vengeurs survivants
s'ils veulent trouver une solution comme
je la firme dans la théorie précédente
il est maintenant sûr que le voyage dans
le temps sera de mise et si nous
regardons une certaine scène nous voyons
natacha et steve regardez la photo de
peggy carter la petite amie de steve
dans sa véritable époque alors je ne
sais pas vous mais moi en voyant ce
passage et du fait qu'il parle de mener
le combat de leur vie
je suis certain que captain va retrouver
peggy dans son époque
peu importe les raisons trouver les
pierres avant la noce changer le passé
bref il va retrouver peggy c'est certain
sa photo est sur une boussole une image
forte
symbolisant que la direction à suivre et
peggy que c'est là où il doit aller là
où il doit retourner quand il est perdu
ce dernier pourrait enfin avoir sa
dernière danse avec celle ci les deux
amoureux sont toujours promis de se
revoir pour un rendez vous mais comme
vous le savez
captain avait dû se sacrifier pour
vaincre crâne rouge peggy n'est
mentionné que très peu de fois par le
capitaine dans le mc eu qui ne dévoile
jamais ses sentiments montrer cette
photo à natacha en parlant de combats
ultimes prouve pour moi le voyage dans
le temps et le retour à l'époque de
notre héros steve rogers est sur la
sellette depuis pas mal de temps
avengers 4 va amener de lourdes
conséquences pour rester cohérent il est
sûr pour moi que si des héros doivent
mourir ou nous quitter ce sera forcément
un ou plusieurs des premiers avengers
et puis tous ceux qui ont disparu sont
déjà morts techniquement le capitaine a
enfin une chance de retourner à son
époque d'origine et retrouver sa chère
et tendre qu'il a dû abandonner même si
le capitaine survie à toute l'histoire
et qu'ils réussissent à ramener nos
héros aient la paix ce dernier voudra
très certainement s'en aller pour
retrouver peggy j'en suis certain tony
stark est également sur la sellette lui
est captain sont les deux héros les plus
supposé de mourir dans avengers 4 et ce
depuis un bon moment
justement tony agoniser seul dans
l'espace dans le vaisseau des gardiens
cette scène est paradoxal car c'est la
première scène qui nous est montré dans
le trailer mais il est fortement
supposer qu'elle se passe vers le milieu
ou la fin du film nebula était aux côtés
de toni à la base mais a certainement dû
s'éclipser suite à plusieurs péripéties
pareil pour le casque de l'armure de
tony ce casque ne fait pas partie de
l'armure qu'il possédait dans une finity
voir tony a dû sûrement bricoler quelque
chose ou avait ce dos aux armures de
secours il est évident que si le grand
ironman doit mourir
ce ne sera pas seul à famille est
asphyxié dans l'espace le plus supposé
serait que captain marvel viennent à son
secours
grâce à un signal de détresse par
exemple c'est la seule lettre dans
l'espace en ce moment même personne ne
sait où est honni à part nebula ou bien
peut-être tort concernant tort je ne
vous cache pas être assez désemparé pour
lui ce dernier a tout perdu royaume
famille amis
il n'a plus rien à perdre alors oui
walkyrie et des asgardiens son cachet et
il est sûr que thor va les retrouver mes
torts arrive vraiment au bout de ces
péripéties il est l'un des personnages
qui a le plus évolué
l'un des plus vieux avengers du mc lui
il n'a plus rien à perdre je le répète
le dieu vivant s'est fait avoir par
thanos
pour finir j'aimerais que nous parlions
changement entre guillemets de
l'évolution des personnages du mc eu que
sont ils devenus denrées wenders endgame
et où sont ils il est facile de
comprendre que nous sommes quelques
semaines voire mois après les évènements
d'une finity war
la plupart des héros sont partis en
poussière et ceux restant ne peuvent
savoir qui a réellement disparu
nous voyons justement natacha steve et
banner semblait faire une sorte de bilan
des gens qui auraient disparu les photos
avec marquez et missing qui d'ailleurs
vaudrait dire disparu et où manquent à
l'appel ils ne considèrent pas forcément
les autres comme mort scott est
considérée comme disparue et pourtant il
est bel et bien présent à la fin du
trailer
ceci prouve comme quoi les gens qu'ils
considèrent comme manquant à l'appel ne
sont pas forcément mordu au claquement
de doigts on peut prendre l'exemple de
souris nous ne voyons pas xuri
disparaître du claquement de doigts et
pourtant elle va devenir de plus en plus
importantes au fil des épisodes
donc elle n'est pas morte pour moi au
contraire tête xala lui est parti en
poussière il faut quelqu'un pour
maintenir le wac honda flow suite à ce
traumatisme souris va certainement guidé
le peuple le temps de la disparition de
son frère dans les comics elles portent
même la tenue de black panthères elle va
avoir son importance
puis d'ailleurs je vous rappelle qu'elle
s'occupait à la base de la survie de
vision je ne veux pas m'avancer mais
elle a peut-être réussi à tirer quelque
chose pendant le combat contre thanos
pour continuer nous pouvons parler de
hawkeye et tu te fais une grosse dédié
aerokart il m'en avait parlé il ya
quelques temps et ça se concrétise enfin
effectivement aux cayes devenu ronin
semble devenir assez malveillants six
derniers tuent des gens de sang froid et
a certainement perdu sa famille compte à
nos sfi le claquement de doigts nous le
remarquons avec les dialogues en rapport
avec les images montrées nous avons
perdu de la famille et une part de nous
mêmes dialogues qui survient pile au
moment de son apparition
ceci prouve bien qu aux caïds viendrait
à c'est malveillant car les avenger sont
échoués face à tan hausse est donc cette
défaite lui fit perdre sa famille je
vous conseille l'excellente vidéo de
l'ami aéro qui avait développé cette
idée justement ensuite wang c'est
exactement comme souris il est forcément
toujours présent on l'aurait vu
disparaître sinon ce dernier aura aussi
son importance notamment en rapport avec
le docteur stress
strange est supposé revenir en tant que
corps astral après sa disparition il
pourrait alors communiqué avec wang pour
mettre à bien son plan
je vous rappelle tout de même que ce
dernier possède la clé de la victoire
contre thanos une seule chance sur 14
millions oui j'aimerais enfin revenir
sur tony stark et notamment de sa place
dans le mc ou disons le tony stark est
le symbole entre guillemets des avengers
comme une sorte de leader il est à la
base de tout il est temps piliers
fondateurs pour nos héros il est donc
certain que son personnage sera centrale
dans avengers 4 et pour parler un peu de
tony j'aimerais justement revenir
particulièrement sur avengers 2 et les
visions de nos héros je voulais à la
base faire une vidéo entière sur ses
visions et ce qu'elle apporte pour le
futur du mc eu mais je pense qu'en
parler plus brièvement est une meilleure
idée tony se prépare depuis toujours à
une menace comme thanos il est même
étrangement lié aux titans puisque ce
dernier le reconnaît et le respectent ce
sont tous les deux des visionnaires des
gens en avance sur leur temps et qui
veulent prévenir le futur on le remarque
beaucoup à l'évolution de l'armure de
tony par exemple et son équipement à
chaque nouveau film dans sa vision
provoqué par rwanda tony se voit comme
celui qui a tué les avengers et le reste
du monde
nous pouvons vite faire le rapprochement
avec une finition noire ou la moitié de
l'existence des êtres vivants a disparu
dans nos héros tony était absent de la
terre car il était sur titan il n'a donc
pas pu aider ses compagnons ironman a
des regrets et a perdu il est obligé que
ce dernier ait culpabilisés par rapport
à ça si on lit le tout à sa vision
je rappelle encore une fois que strange
a d'ailleurs sacrifier la pierre du
temps à thanos et lui a donc donné la
victoire pour que tony reste en vie afin
d'amener son plan à exécution
si nous regardons le visage de thanos il
en est même étonné il se demande
pourquoi quelque chose se cache là
dessous
nous pouvons d'ailleurs amené facilement
captain marvel et les celles qui
risquent de sauver tony de sa solitude
dans l'espace ces deux protagonistes
pourraient certainement être liés grâce
au père de tony howard stark a mené
captain marvel a rencontré tony en
premier pourrait permettre une facilité
scénaristique grâce au projet pegasus
lancé par howard stark le projet pegasus
était d'étudier les phénomènes dépassant
les limites de
compréhension scientifique
conventionnelle donc l'étude
extraterrestres en quelque sorte avec le
tesseract etc
ce projet a été lancé par la nasa et le
shield via awards
captain marvel a très bien pu faire
partie du projet pour revenir aux
visions tort avait également eu une
vision qu'il approfondit nous montrons
au final les pierres d'infinité et le
gant de l'infini sa vision était
prémonitoire
si nous voulons faire écho à ce que je
vous disais dans la théorie précédente
captain america se revoit son époque
avec peggy lui proposant la fameuse
danse et lui affirmant qu'il est à la
maison grâce au voyage dans le temps et
ce qui nous est montré la vision de toni
et celle du capitaine pourrait être des
prévisions d'avengers 4
je tenais vraiment à m'excuser déjà pour
le retard mais également pour ceux trois
théories qui est un petit peu plus
décousu
on va dire que d'habitude le trailer est
difficile à décortiquer et on quitte un
petit peu les trois théorie
traditionnelle
j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu j'ai
plus que hâte de voir avengers 4 et
comptait sur moi si j'ai d'autres idées
concernant le film
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter a
laissé un petit pouce bleu un petit
commentaire
et à vous abonner vous pouvez également
me soutenir financièrement via utile
abonnez-vous à la chaîne d'aéronefs
l'explorateur d'univers cet argot rock
et heroes cf pour vous servir que le
liner soit avec vous
[Musique]
et